walter ich etwas cooles finden
was bringt mir das an den freunden und
willkommen zu einem neuen projekt auf
meinem kanal und auch auf dem kanal von
topshop media hallo ihr drei erstmal und
22 web the walls also ich glaub rennen
okay gut wir wurden jetzt schon alle
hoch gelegt wollt ihr das mal ganz kurz
erklären was das ist oder so ich das
eben kurz machen kann normal haben also
wir haben hier so vier parzellen jeder
hat eigentlich glaube ich den gleichen
abschnitt sozusagen und dass es durch
ein kreuz aus sand getrennt mit umgang
dazwischen oder so auf jeden fall nach
35 minuten fertig wand runter und dann
geht es los dann der lage alle
gegeneinander vorbereitungsphase
wir haben ja alle wie lange haben wir
zeit 35 minuten 30 ist er so ein timer
jeder hat das im kreis hinter
unterschieden
tagsüber ein bisschen schwer zu erkennen
york gratis ein monster sind übrigens
aus so stand es in den regeln
ja also um das noch mal ganz ganz kurz
kurz zusammenzufassen wir sind in einer
großen welt die in vier gesplittet ist
die überall gleich ist sage ich mal
und jeder hat quasi das gleiche gebiet
muss ich dann an anderen von holz und
alle möglichen sachen in die waffen
machen usw und nach der diesem countern
also nach 35 minuten werden dann diese
sand wendet die ich hier gerade angucke
also dass ungefähr
die werden da dann runter gefahren und
dann herrschte quasi zum battle dass wir
alle gegeneinander kämpfen und der der
zuletzt übrig bleibt der ist derart
gewonnene jungs cool
übrigens ein novum auf unserem kanal zum
ersten mal könnt ihr etwas sehen aus
verschiedenen sichten und also planen
ihrer sicht gucken könnte also ich kann
kraft damit seinen teil auf seinem kanal
natürlich hoch link in der beschreibung
und wir haben auf unserem kanal auch
fast alle aus allen drei schichten
jeweils ein video und entscheiden auf
fahrrad oder auf partys und aaron werden
das dann auch einfach so machen wenn ihr
zum beispiel diese partie gerade bei mir
auf dem kanal seht könnt ihr einfach und
mit
beschreibung gucken dort seht ihr dann
den part von kilian räumen und an die
richtig so also separat von den gucken
können da ich hab doch im trailer
irgendwas gesehen mit getreide wie ich
zu blöd
also ich hab also ich hab schon gefunden
da aber muss echt sagen ich habe einen
blick für
wir dürfen jetzt noch gar nicht so viel
über das spiel reden also was wir gerade
machen weil wir natürlich alle gerade
neben beim skypen sind von daher wäre
das unglück wenn jetzt sagen würden ihr
euch wie macht ihr das hier und das hier
und das wäre dann einfach nur total hier
unsinnig wenn wir das machen
scherzhaft ob er jetzt auch noch nichts
gewonnen
ach da ich habe sachen alter was ist da
schon einiges drin beschreibt das ganze
ja nach megamäßig fein und irgendwie in
dem trailer wird auch immer davon
geredet man soll doch irgendwas machen
mit redstone und lekkerland und man wird
sehen was draus wird
ich denke aber und so nicht so doll
welches bisher richtig gerät müsste ich
dann von crafter nicht so viel erwarten
ich bin nicht so ganz gut im redstone
soll ja ich vergesse ich einfach die
ganze also ich habe ich hab mir gerade
noch mal unser unser theorie angeguckt
dabei ich meine ich müsste es ja treffen
entweder die haben mir wirklich tnt
versteckt oder es kann ja nur so sein
weil es gibt ja keine monster auf das
war auch im trailer zu sehen wir bereits
erwähnte er heute ich hab so viel
unsinniges zeug gerade im inventar ja
ich könnte eigentlich alles abbauen halt
nur in dieser parzelle drin die mauer
sollte die ringsherum stehen lassen wir
jetzt mal kohle also ihr könnt euch in
den neueren nicht in anderen bereichen
der messe quasi sind 35 minuten
eingesperrt und danach
werden wir aufeinander losgelassen
allein für die dunkelheit aber ich finde
keine kohle moment nicht wahr nach
fackeln auf den zäunen
die nehme ich verstehe das gar nicht ich
hab so viel unsinniges zeug in einem
inventar ja es ist dann richtig krass
was die einem jahr alles mitgeben
ich versteh einer alten dame tor ist für
mich zu sammeln ist er hat ist habe ich
auch nicht gemacht so jetzt muss man
offen ein bisschen gras kann man ja
verraten man sollte mich verraten wo man
besonders geile sachen findet so zwei
holz
ich glaube uns habe ich noch monster
sind aus oder er hat mir hier gut dass
das thema so das gefühl einer von
verfolgungen sterben ich weiß wirklich
das gefühl einmal täglich viele fischer
gerade junge ich sage dass ich nach
holzbogen erkennen wo ich bitte euch
richtig mies weg gebracht hast das
schiff wo ihr habt verarbeitete holz
verbrennen oder und verarbeitet und
verarbeitetes holzofen tun unten nach
oben rutschen
doch geht ich hab gerade nein das geht
nicht wenn ich frage dann halt doch so
wie es ist wenn hertie nicht ändern
nichts dran rütteln
ich glaube ich sollte auf eingehen zu
sprinten zum unglaublich wie die leute
es schaffen mit so einem schwachsinn ja
einige skripte schon so bekannt zu
werden
vor allem jeder kennt den irgendwie wenn
du mehr über die berliner straße geht
und scheiß ganz dort halt stopp
irgendeiner grenzt ihr eindringen wieder
da könnt ihr den typen irgendwie das ist
raus genau sie da gerät
ich bin sie an einer wand angelangt
tolle wurst und ich haben uns gefunden
in dem das inventar geöffnet
gibt sie so richtig zuerst mäßig so wenn
ich mich ja ja ja das hast du das hatte
ich schon vorgesehen sollen jetzt wieder
hoch um mir das kannst du nicht mein
gott was porsche gefunden
er riecht die forschungsfelder ich bin
sofort drauf gestolpert und noch ein
paar sekunden klar wer das ganze
irgendwie danach mache ich alles wird
alles überprüft mahlstein equipment
bauen ja jede ledl findet die recht
interessante sachen ein wenig sagen ich
möchte ja ich möchte auch nicht sagen
ich glaube ich weiß was du gefunden hast
weißt es nicht doch ich wenn er das
gefunden was ich gefunden hat dann ist
er genauso überrascht ich werde jetzt
hier erstmal versuchen irgendwas zu
bauen aber ich werde das wie die schief
gehen wir meinen baus gilt ich warne die
seiner haut
ich möchte nicht zu viel verraten aber
ich habe auch gerade etwas entdeckt gott
alle entdecken was nicht es wäre also
hat es nicht ich glaube dass glücklich
schätzen dass mazda kompensiert das
wieder
du hast viele zu kompensieren nein ich
hasse diese momente ich mache die ich
gehe auf dem crafting table macht der
rechtsklick drauf bin damit menü und
frag mich was wollte jetzt eigentlich
machen ja manchmal schon so aus setzte
irgendwie das typische verstecke für so
was man darf doch auch blöcke setzen
richtig natürlich okay gut eine blöde
frage aber auch nachdem diese wende
unten sind also dann darf die ecke da
nur nicht die die wand über bauen und so
was die erde die wand abreißen also
keine und werten die daten dann habe ich
eine idee dann habe ich eine idee
das wird es auch dass wir uns gar nicht
gegenseitig beuteln können gerade weil
wir das alles an einem stück aufnehmen
das heißt ihr braucht jetzt gar nicht in
die kommentare schreiben
er leitet das gleichzeitig hoch und ihr
könnt ja gegenseitig bei der anderen
abspecken das geht nicht weil wir haben
wir zocken jetzt einfach die ganze zeit
nano ist die ganze nacht stundenlang
direkt vom pc doch was hier hinter eine
geräusche machen mir angst
da bleibt ja dadurch geht ja holzbogen
aqim wurde ein hamam ach so heißen sind
unglaublich oh mein gott wie ich 66 26
also in etwa ich frag mich die ganze
zeit vielleicht dieser experience kriege
das ist ja mittlerweile auch wenn man
blöcke abbaut
also gibt es jetzt hier auch unter der
erde erz und sofija gibt es immer noch
hat jetzt nicht geändert neben minecraft
gibt es unter der ärzte aber nicht
minecraft werdet ihr auf einer
herrlichen minecraft selbst gebaut denke
ich mal schon also ja die bäume hat er
wahrscheinlich mit boden wie gemacht
bildschirm zu trauen
vielleicht hat das japan gebaut selbst
sein glaube ich nicht wer weiß wer weiß
ich glaube ich bin der der bisher am
wenigsten gebracht hat von uns glaube
ich schon
kannst du nicht glaubst du was hasst das
sich bis am wenigsten gemacht habe ich
kenne das item nicht mal also weg so
hieß diese sind jemand nach weißwasser
geburt hat ich weiß auf was er gefunden
hat es ist rund 30 ende oder was ja ende
1000 dollar dann wissen ja wahr herr ich
weiß gar nicht was kann ich damit
anfangen könnte doch mal testet auch ein
bisschen mit ich kann damit mit
rechtsklick auf den boden und dann
wenn ich oder wie du kannst es glaube
ich aus dispenser und dann ist es also
ein komisches feier schiessling okay
gesagt für das junge ich hab so mies
experience sich verzaubern hier mies
eins weiß ich aus der beschreibung den
einst ist ein diamanten gibt es in der
welt als er meine ich doch verteilen
manchmal aber auch mal eine milliarde dm
mehrere glaub ich aber die gibt
irgendwie nur in der mitte glaube ich in
der mitte jetzt von denen von den wänden
oder jahr fällig das jetzt und weg weil
das ist schon okay so vor als 2
eigentlich wollte mit teil 1 spiel und
wir haben so lange gebraucht ist dass
wir ein zweiter junger diese der adern
sind aber hier auch gut also wenn du was
findest dann - 24 jung macht nicht so
stressig gehe ich weiß einfach gleich
was ich machen soll um so etwas zu bauen
was die da hatte er recht
da reicht die zeit bei
raus sein ich will jetzt auch noch
irgendwas kolles finden da ich weiß
schon wer gewinnt gewinnt garantiert
das wild aber dafür muss ich erst mal
diamant aus der mitte kriegen er hat
schon längst vielleicht habe ich längst
eingefunden
dann weiß ich ja nicht schon wieder
vergessen was ich gerade machen wollte
ich weiß nicht wo durch drei herzen
verloren aber wahrscheinlich vom
runterspringen oder verhungern wieder in
den tief sind
es kommt jetzt schlag auf schlag der
baum gefällt was ich habe mitgemacht
wenn es nach dem video angucken peaches
war kaputt
unter wasser an block abbauen und dann
rutsch ausgerückt
bei minecraft aus ja es war schlimm ich
am boden
ich habe heute zum ersten mal minecraft
auf der xbox gespielt es ist witzig
irgendwie geht zur ein junge das war
auch nur die testversion gibt sogar ein
tutorial leute dich nicht immer kommen
ja siehst du unfähige leute
konsolenspieler hat ja lass mich noch da
oben muss doch dass der pc an den
konsolen leiden muss das auch noch
ich glaube ich könnte mich hier unten so
lange aufhalten bis ich würde es gar
nicht bemerken dass es losgeht da
versteht welchen die pisten zellen die
das ganze freigeben aber wahrscheinlich
ich verstehe gar nicht bei mir ich finde
gar nicht sondern solche tollen gänge
die du da findest du wenn du erstmal was
findest dann ich glaube dann hängt
wahrscheinlich alles zusammen weil so
groß wie das ist was ich gefunden habe
walter ich war fast alles finden was
bringt auch gänzlich spätestens jetzt
fühle ich mich scheiße was bringt das
was ich gefunden habe
toll aus dass also toll aus aber das
bringt man ich muss an die ganzen neuen
items kennen werden was und jetzt ein
update vorstellungen weißt nicht was was
ist da doch ich weiß was er bringt aber
nicht den peters war knapp was dann auch
so bist du tot cool
es würde nein ich brauche kann man als
sterbende von anleihen umgebracht zu
werden das ja die höhe wie das denn
inzwischen wieder tag
ich frage mich gerade was passieren
passiert dass ich glaube ich kommt mir
das später mal ich glaub ich auch jetzt
und wir haben von gesagt eigentlich
könntet ihr euch alles gleichzeitig ein
gucken und zwar müsst ihr alle vier
videos gleichzeitig aufmachen bei einem
den ton an lassen weil er gleichzeitig
statt alle gleichzeitig starten
unterhalt bei den anderen schon
ausmachen
da habt ihr halt nur von einem den abbau
sound und so aber erhalten
ihr hört ja alle und so möchte ich es